marine corps three c_i_a_ secret wars i
had a position in the national security
council
in nineteen seventy five is the chief of
the angola
uh... task force running the secret war
in angola is a third c_i_a_ secret
worlds part of the national security
uh...
lol
creating a national security council
missy i should know was passed in
nineteen forty-seven
the c_i_a_ was given this charter
perform such other duties and functions
might be nice nicer the national
security interests
and given a vague according to protect
it's worth it sources and methods
i think it was in the mid eighties the
tyco and has frayed the thorough
third world war because in my research i
realized that we were not attacking the
soviet union and the c_i_a_'s activities
we were attacking people in the third
world
and i'm going to just quickly in the
interest of time just give you a little
sense of what that
uh... what that means this third world
war
uh... basically it's the third
i believe in terms of loss of life and
human destruction of third bloodiest war
and all of
history
they undertake to run operations in
every corner of the global
uh... they also undertook the license of
operating
totally above and beyond u_s_ law story
had a license if you will to kill but
also they they took that to a
light-sensitive smuggle drugs
a license to
do all kinds of things to other people
and other societies and violation
of international our law
and every principle of nations working
together for a healthier and more
peaceful
uh... world meanwhile again they battle
to convert the u_s_ legal system
and such a way that it would give them
control of our society
now we have
massive documentation of what they call
the secret wars of the c_i_a_ we don't
have to guess or speculate
we had the church committee investigate
them
and nineteen seventy-five gave us our
first really in depth
powerful look inside the structure
senator church said
and the fourteen years before he did his
investigation
that he found they had run nine hundred
major operations and three thousand
minor operations and if you extrapolate
that over the whole period of the forty
odd years that we've had a c_i_a_
you come up with three thousand major
operations in over ten thousand minor
operations
every one of them illegal
everyone up on destructive of the lives
and societies of other people's
and many of them bloody and gory
uh...
beyond comprehension almost
uh... it extensively we manipulated in
organized the overthrow of functioning
constitutional democracies and other
countries
we organized secret armies and directed
them to fight and just about every
continent in the world we encourage
ethnic minority
to rise up and fight people like
mosquito onions and nicaragua
or kurtz in the middle east amongst them
and south east asian of course
we have organized and we still do an
fund death squads and countries around
the world like the treasury police tell
salvador which a responsible for most of
the killing of a fifty thousand people
just in the eighties and it was seventy
thousand
before that
an orchestration c_i_a_ secret teams and
propaganda
let us directly into the cree in war we
were attacking china from the island's
pay more not sue thailand tibet
uh... a lot of drug trafficking involved
in this by the way until eventually we
convinced ourselves to fight the chinese
and korean met the korean war in a
million people were killed
same thing for the vietnam war and we
have extensive documentation of how the
c_i_a_ was involved at every level of
the national security complex but it's a
very cooperative thing
and to manipulating the nation end to
the vietnam war and we wound up creating
the golden triangle in which the c_i_a_
america planes were flying an arms to
our allies and flying back out with for
her one
we launched a map of the largest this is
something that jimmy carter did admiral
turner brags about it
the the operation
uh... in afghanistan
biggest single operation i'm told and
the history of the c_i_a_ secret wars
and sure enough very quickly we produce
the golden crescent
which is still the largest source of her
own perhaps in the world today
trying to summarize this third world war
that the c_i_a_ the u_s_ national
security complex with the military all
interwoven edit in many different ways
has been waging
let me just put it this way the best
heads that i coordinate with studying
this thing we count at least minimum
figure
six million people
who've been killed and those long forty
year war that we've waged against the
people of the third world
these are not soviets we have not been
pressured eighteen ten of the soviet
union kill and her two main people
uh... especially not since nineteen
fifty four when they developed actually
capability of dropping atomic weapons on
the united states
britain british
french swede swiss
belgians we don't do bloody gory
operations
uh... and the countries of europe these
are all people of the third world
they're people of countries like the
congo
vietnam
complex shia
and tunisia
nicaragua where conspicuously
they nor their governments do not have
that capability of doing any physical
her to the united states they don't have
i_c_b_m_'s they don't have armies are
navy's they could not purpose if they
wanted to there's really been any
evidence that they really wanted to and
that in fact is perhaps the whole point
if they had had i_c_b_m_s we probably
wouldn't have done nothing storm
first-served retaliation
cheap shots if you will killing people
of other countries of the world
who cannot defend themselves under the
guise of secrecy
and under the uh... the rubric of
national security